Nikki yes good afternoon dr. Wilhite how
can we help you
well I'm 51 five for 150 I have no
health insurance
I had constipation as a young child dots
on the back of my upper back of my upper
arms as a teenager I tried to go
gluten-free just recently I don't eat
out I don't need any msg I eat only
organic fresh food from my own edge if
it's not organic I don't eat it I'm
gonna drink only want water I have a
smoothie every day and a big salad okay
so what do you explain you're calling me
FAR's what are you calling me for enough
I think I have gall stones okay
Internet's half from my bellybutton to
the side sometimes hurts in the back by
my ribs I'm I don't have insurance I'm
going to miss you a little on the
toilets Tony okay let's stop here for a
second as a kid did you have any history
of asthma bronchitis no did you know any
history of skin problems eczema
dermatitis psoriasis keratosis eczema I
had I had a newborn or two with cradle
cap but not myself that I know of okay
okay how many children do you have
three okay do they have any respiratory
problems or skin problems now our bowel
problems now my son has fistula it she
rectum skin his scans like a sticker
texture I don't know because he's
redhead but usually a pension register
David anyone know he's got thick skin
but yes okay okay so angry see here char
what's going on here how can we help
Nikki you know she's got a little bit of
discomfort around her belly button she
has had several kids cradle cap
she had keratosis when she was a kid you
know that were the rough skin on the
back of her neck and arms and let's see
here
she
as a history constipation she weighs 150
pounds she's 5 foot 4 what would you do
for her well she said she's on a
gluten-free diet but those are in my
opinion gluten problems mm-hmm she
cranked got a crank down on I didn't
really get serious and obsessive about
three anyway I was and what program
would you put her on well I would get
her on it I would get her she's at the
cusp for all her issues I'd get her on a
brain and heart pack and and she still
needs to take some enzymes probably some
digestive enzymes are actually she could
start out with taking the rainforest at
night before she goes to bed and see if
that works
mm-hmm okay that's good okay so let me
pick up on this okay as char said I'd go
ahead and get the the herbal rainforest
which has 12 cleansing herbs as well as
a 78 minerals in it and we got off all
the bad foods no products is no process
means no oils on glutinous you know
about that nobody brought her a notes
that includes dog can't bird fish mouse
partner mother-in-law kids renter okay
everybody's got to be gluten free
because across contamination the laundry
the food preparation services couches
and beds and so on then hey char said I
would go ahead with two healthy brain
and heart packs per month to how the
brain and heart attacks per month to
fold oh so everything twice sitting I'd
also get two bottles a month of the
gluco gel capsules you can take 15 of
those a day five breakfasts lunches
there they're designed to support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between vertebrae bone matrix bone
and cell and then also it has special
stuff in there that your your liver
loves we have gall stones it's usually a
liver problem
gall bladder does not produce gall
stones it's just an empty bag and gall
stones are made in the liver and drop
down into the gall bladder and then we
want you to also get the vitamin d3 you
can take three of those capsules twice a
day that's two bottles a month it also
take the let's see here the MSM take
sure those tablets twice it is to about
a month and if I went too fast earlier
on the herbal rainforest you want to
take I start out with a tablespoon 1/2
ounce of the herbal rainforest which is
a liquid comes from quartz if you
continue a tablespoon like 15 or 20
minutes for a bedtime with a half glass
of water 1/2 ounce so that one quart
will last you two months
see if they can help you with the
constipation also it has a cleansing
effect liver cleanse intestinal you know
colon cleanse blood cleanse and using
the old herbal terms and often times you
may get in your bowel movement whole tea
cup full of gall stones that come out
when you take cleanse and of course
again ero rainforest is a legendary
cleanser it has cascara Sagrada tract
succumb and all that the iconic herbs in
there so you want to do that